Christopher Rey is Donald Trump's FBI
director nominee to replace the fired
James Comey Donald Trump tweeted about
this back on June 7th it was a big deal
at the time Donald Trump making the big
announcement on Twitter saying that I
will be nominating Christopher a ray a
man of impeccable credentials to be the
new director of the FBI details to
follow presumably not on Twitter part of
those impeccable credentials are
connected to Russia raised law firm King
and Spaulding represents wait for it two
of Russia's largest state controlled oil
companies Gazprom and the now infamous
Rosneft and we've since learned that
Christopher Rea also represented an
American Energy executive in 2006 who is
being criminally investigated by the
Russian government that detail the key
detail there is that you used to be able
to go on the King & Spalding website and
read about that aspect of Christopher
Ray's attorney past all the way back to
2009 if you went to the King & Spalding
website you would see oh that's
interesting that's something that
Christopher Rea worked on but suddenly
Pat it's gone now scrubbing a public
biography is obviously not a crime
the fact that amidst a Russia scandal
the incoming FBI director nominee has to
scrub their biography to remove
connections to Russia that certainly yet
again raises the obvious questions we've
been asking for a long time which is
what are the connections between Donald
Trump's entire team and Russia and as a
more general principle scrubbing
information from the internet is not an
acceptable reasonable method of dealing
with the appearance of conflicts of
interest it's sort of the Mike Flint
approach right if things look bad just
don't report them and pretend they never
happened it's just interesting because
if you were to make a Venn diagram of
public officials who would be qualified
for any given position yeah and public
officials that are connected to Russia
there wouldn't necessarily be a lot of
overlap but Trump keeps finding the
right guys I mean Christopher Rey is
former campaign manager
oh man afford the coronary long dirty
advisor Michael Flynn I completely agree
with what you're saying and well let me
come back to my thoughts about that
what's Trump going to do next ask his
staff if maybe they could just delete
the internet it would solve a lot of
problems for Trump the law firm was
asked about this and they said well Rhea
changed it himself in January and it
wasn't at all connected to his possible
consideration for a government role they
put out a statement saying quote Chris
made this change to his bio along with
other minor tweaks in an attempt to make
the material more current at the time he
made the adjustments January of 2017 he
was not being considered for and did not
anticipate being nominated for FBI
director or any position in government
moreover the representation that was
dropped from his online bio related to a
matter where Chris King and Spaulding
and the client were adverse to the
Russian government mr. ray worked on
this matter in 2006 other attorneys at
the firm worked on it in oh six oh seven
and twenty eleven of course again this
isn't the only Russia connection I went
into detail about the others last week
or the week before but the bigger
picture is what Pat mentioned earlier
why is it always Russia why is it always
ties to Russia it's never Trump's lawyer
tied to Equatorial Guinea or French
Guiana right we never hear Trump leaks
Israeli Intel to Chilean ambassador it's
the Russian ambassador and that's where
it gets really really weird
simply as a matter of mathematics in a
matter of chance and we've not heard any
reasonable explanation to that